PROPERTY-BY-PROPERTY, SO WE'LL
SEE.
>> THAT WAS A MOUTHFUL, DON, YOU
WERE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
ENJOY YOURSELF.
>> SEE YOU LATER.
>>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT"
AND THIS REALLY HASN'T BEEN A
GOOD 24 HOURS FOR DONALD TRUMP.
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THIS.
BUT FIRST OFF BECAUSE OF HIS
HAND PICKED SPECIAL MASTER
BASICALLY TOLD HIM TO PUT UP OR
SHUT UP.
NOW A FEDERAL APPEALS COURT IS
CALLING OUT HIS LEGAL TEAM FOR
REFUSING TO PROVIDE A SHRED OF
EVIDENCE FOR HIS CLAIMS THAT HE
DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOUND IN
THE SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO, SO
THEY'RE ALLOWING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE LOOKING
AT THOSE DOCUMENTS, UPENDING A
TRIAL JUDGE'S ORDER THAT THE
REVIEW BE BLOCKED, OR BLOCK THE
REVIEW.
AND FIRST ON CNN, A SOURCE SAYS
THAT GINNI THOMAS, A
CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST, WIFE OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS, AGREEING TO TALK TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
AND DON'T FORGET THAT MASSIVE
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, THREE OF HIS ADULT
CHILDREN AND THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION ALLEGING THAT THEIR
WHOLE BUSINESS IS ESSENTIALLY A
GIANT FRAUD.
THAT'S WHAT THESE DOCUMENTS SAY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ALLEGE.
LETITIA JAMES, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF NEW YORK, SAYS THAT
THE FRAUD WAS, AND I QUOTE HERE,
APPROVED AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION,
INCLUDING BY MR. TRUMP HIMSELF.
SHE ALLEGES THAT ERIC TRUMP,
IVANKA TRUMP APPEAR DONALD TRUMP
JR. KNOWINGLY PARTICIPATED IN
THE FRAUDULENT SCHEMES.
SHE SAYS TRUMP AND HIS COMPANY
LIED MORE THAN 200 TIMES ABOUT
THE VALUE OF HIS ASSETS, AND SHE
IS SEEKING A QUARTER OF A
BILLION DOLLARS, THAT'S BILLION
WITH A B, IN ALLEGEDLY
ILL-GOTTEN FUNDS AS WELL AS
SEEKING TO BAR THE TRUMPS FROM
EVER RUNNING A BUSINESS IN THE
STATE AGAIN.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT DENIES ANY
WRONGDOING AND ACCUSES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, A DEMOCRAT, OF
A POLITICAL VENDETTA.
THERE IS A LOT TO THE TO IN THE
COMING HOURS HERE ON CNN, SO I
WANT TO GET RIGHT TO JESSICA
SCHNEIDER AND LAURA COATES.
GOOD EVENING TO BOTH OF YOU.
JESSICA, FURTHER REPORTING, THE
APPEALS COURT ALLOWING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO RESUME
THEIR REVIEW OF THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> DON, THIS WAS A UNANIMOUS
THREE-JUDGE PANEL NOTABLY WITH
TWO TRUMP APPOINTEES.
THEY GAVE DOJ WHAT THE
PROSECUTORS THERE HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR REPEATEDLY OVER THE
PAST WEEK PLUS.
NOW DOJ WILL BE ALLOWED TO
RESUME USING THOSE 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT THE
FBI SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO IN
THEIR SEARCH JUST ABOUT A MONTH
AGO.
THEY CAN USE IT IN THEIR ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
THIS HAS BEEN A HUGE POINT OF
CONTENTION FOR PROSECUTORS
BECAUSE THE LOWER COURT JUDGE,
AILEEN CANNON, SHE HAD HALTED
THEIR USE OF THESE CLASSIFIED
RECORDS, MEANING THEY COULDN'T
USE IT FOR GRAND JURY PURPOSES
OR WITH WITNESSES.
NOW THEY CAN.
AND THE APPEALS COURT STRESSED
HERE WHEN THEY SIDED WITH DOJ
THAT REALLY IT COULD HARM THE
COUNTRY IF INVESTIGATORS
COULDN'T USE THAT MATERIAL.
HERE'S WHAT THEY SAID IN PART.
IT IS SELF-EVIDENT THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS A STRONG INTEREST IN
ENSURING THE STORAGE OF THE
CLASSIFIED RECORDS DID NOT
RESULT IN EXCEPTIONALLY GRAVE
DAMAGE TO THE NATIONAL SECURITY.
ASCERTAINING THAT NECESSARILY
INVOLVES REVIEWING THE
DOCUMENTS, DETERMINING WHO HAD
ACCESS TO THEM AND WHEN AND
DECIDING WHICH IF ANY SOURCES OR
METHODS ARE COMPROMISED.
THE COURT THERE SAYING DOJ
NEEDED TO LOOK AT THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
NOW DOJ DOES HAVE THE GREEN
LIGHT TO RESUME USING THEM, ALL
WHILE THE SPECIAL MASTER AND
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM WILL NO
LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THAT WAS THE SECOND THING THE
DOJ ASKED FOR.
SO A BIG WIN TONIGHT FOR DOJ AT
THE 11th CIRCUIT, DON.
>> LAURA, LISTEN, ALL OF THIS
WAS BECAUSE TEAM TRUMP WANTED A
SPECIAL MASTER, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, SO ON, SO ON AND SO ON.
SO WHAT IMPACT DOES THE DOJ
APPEAL HAVE ON WHAT THE SPECIAL
MASTER IS DECIDING NOW?
>> WELL, IT'S LIMITING NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT TINA TURNER SONG
"WHAT'S LOVE GOT TO DO WITH IT,"
DON?
NOW WHAT DID THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HAVE TO DO WITH YOUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE
PRIVILEGED.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
APPEALS COURT SAID.
YOU'VE GOT THESE 100 DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE ABOUT CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS, HAVE THESE VARIOUS
LABELS ON THEM THAT SAY, LOOK,
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT
THIS.
BY ALLOWING A SPECIAL MASTER OR
ANYONE TO SEE IT BUT UNDER THE
PRETEXT OF I'M LOOKING FOR
PRIVILEGED DOCUMENTS, YOU'RE
GOING TO ALLOW PEOPLE WHO DON'T
OTHERWISE HAVE A CLEARANCE OR
OTHERWISE AUTHORIZED TO SEE WHAT
COULD BE THE MOST SENSITIVE
INFORMATION NOW SEE IT.
SO NOW THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
LIMITED IN THAT.
THE OAR PART OF THAT, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, A LOT OF THIS IS A
SELF-INFLICTED WOUND FROM THE
TRUMP LEGAL TEAM AND DONALD
TRUMP HIMSELF BY SPEAKING OUT IN
PUBLIC, TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT HE HAS
DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
WHEN IT CAME TO ACTUALLY BACKING
THAT UP IN A COURTROOM YESTERDAY
AND THAT SPECIAL MASTER, THEY
DIDN'T DO SO.
THAT WAS TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
TODAY BY THE 11th CIRCUIT, TWO
OF WHOM WERE ACTUAL TRUMP
APPOINTEES, ONE WAS AN OBAMA
APPOINTEE THAT ESSENTIALLY SAID
WHEN YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
US ABOUT WHAT THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HAD TO DO WITH YOUR
PARTICULAR ROLE, YOU DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING, AND THAT WAS USED
AGAINST THEM NOW.
>> JESSICA, AND THIS NOW
PREVENTS IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IT PREVENTS TEAM TRUMP OR
TRUMP'S TEAM FROM SEEING THE
RECORDS WITH CLASSIFICATION
MARKINGS, CORRECT?
>> IT DOES, EXACTLY.
IT PREVENTS TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
AS WELL AS THE SPECIAL MASTER AS
LAURA WAS GETTING TO FROM SEEING
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
LAURA MENTIONED IT.
WHAT WAS INTERESTING IS THAT
YESTERDAY'S HEARING BEFORE THE
SPECIAL MASTER, TRUMP'S TEAM HAD
ARGUED THAT THEY NEEDED TO SEE
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
DETERMINE WHICH ONES TRUMP HAD
POTENTIALLY DECLASSIFIED.
AND THAT WAS ANOTHER AREA WHERE
THE 11th CIRCUIT CALLED OUT
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
YOU KNOW, THEY SAID THAT SO FAR
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM HAS REFUSED
TO PRESENT ANY EVIDENCE AT ALL
THAT TRUMP DECLASSIFIED ANY OF
THESE DOCUMENTS.
YOU KNOW, PLUS THE 11th CIRCUIT
MADE ONE MORE POINT THAT TRUMP
JUST HAS NO CLAIM AT ALL TO ANY
OF THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
WRITING FOR OUR PART, WE CANNOT
DISCERN WHY PLAINTIFF WOULD HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL INTEREST IN OR
NEED FOR ANY OF THE 100
DOCUMENTS WITH CLASSIFICATION
MARKINGS.
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE MARKED
TO SHOW THEY ARE CLASSIFIED, FOR
INSTANCE, WITH THEIR
CLASSIFICATION LEVEL.
SO ALL IN ALL, THIS WAS LIKE A
29-PAGE DECISION HERE AND IT
WENT POINT BY POINT TO TAKE DOWN
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM'S ARGUMENTS
ON JUST ABOUT EVERY LEVEL HERE.
NOW THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
TRUMP TEAM DO NEXT, APPEAL TO
THE SUPREME COURT?
>> IT APPEARS THAT THAT'S THEIR
ONLY RECOURSE BECAUSE THERE WAS
SOME QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
THERE COULD BE AN E BANC REVIEW
TO THE 11th CIRCUIT AND THAT
DOES NOT APPLY UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IS THAT THE WAY YOU READ IT?
>> RIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU HAVE A FULL
APPELLATE COURT, CIRCUIT COURT.
YOU ONLY HAVE SEVERAL OF THEM AT
A TIME THAT LISTEN TO CASES IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE REVIEW OF
MATTERS.
AS OPPOSED TO WAITING FOR
EVERYONE TO HEAR A MATTER, THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT THREE-JUDGE
PANELS TO REVIEW DIFFERENT
CASES.
THIS IS ONE SUCH ISSUE.
IF AN EN BANC DECISION WAS
ISSUED, THEY WANT TO GO TO THE
ENTIRETY OF THE CIRCUIT COURT.
NORMALLY YOU CAN DO THAT EXCEPT
FOR NOW THERE'S A NEW RULE AS OF
THIS YEAR IN THE 11th CIRCUIT
THAT IF IT'S AN ORDER FROM A
STAY, WHICH IS WHAT THE DOJ
ASKED FOR, A LIMITED REVIEW THAT
SAID I'D LIKE YOU TO PUT A PIN
IN A PARTICULAR ASPECT OF A
LOWER COURT'S RULE, I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT ORDER IN
A VERY DISCREET AND CONFINED
WAY, A STAY, STAY THE WAY IT WAS
BEFORE THE JUDGE RULED ANYTHING,
A STAY, IF IT'S THAT, THEN YOU
CANNOT THEN GO TO THE REST OF
THE 11th CIRCUIT.
YOUR RECOURSE IS ONLY TO THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND IF PAST RIGHT NOW
IMMEDIATELY IS PROLOGUE, THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE A MAJORITY OF
THE 11th CIRCUI
APPOINTEES, AND EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE APPOINTEES ON THE
SUPREME COURT, WHEN NATIONAL
SECURITY IS AT STAKE, IT'S
UNLIKELY TO CHANGE, BUT STRANG